ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show we apologize we're
a little late not crazy late a couple of
days you know during the next two months
when we're on tour heavily before we get
off for months and months and months uh
you know the episode is going to be
Friday Saturday or maybe Sunday but we
we usually maybe keep it Friday or
Saturday I tried to get David Hogg on
the show I messaged David Hogg uh
survivor of the Parkland school shooting
I messaged him on Instagram and Twitter
and it you know basically saying hey
come on the show like I want to talk
because he's very political and he has
the March for our lives and
save kids not guns this is his stuff and
I'm like I'm not trying to fight with
you or debate with you there's a few
things I might bring up if you come on
but like
I've taken Flack for saying there should
be more restrictions I don't believe in
banning guns but I'm like there should
maybe be a couple more
sensible
restrictions but I I invited him on I
don't think he's he's responded I don't
think he's responded to come on the show
but I thought that would be an
interesting
conversation between me and David Hogg
about
schools and guns and you know all the
craziness that just happened in
Nashville
um with the shooting that just happened
in Nashville where they killed three
children yeah yeah I mean it's
nuts it's crazy
um they're saying Finland
is the happiest country in the world
can you believe this Finland
where children don't get shot
is the happiest [__] or maybe they do I
don't think they do but the Finish are
the happiest people in the world happier
than the United States of America this
is what they're saying this is their
this is the New York Times it has been
ranked the happiest Nation on Earth for
six consecutive years
but in this article they talk to the
individual Finns who are
I don't know
they're not exuberant
they're satisfied
they're like relaxed they go yeah we're
cool
and I read this article we're going to
bring up some interesting
parts of it I don't know again I've I'm
not shocked that America's doesn't rank
because again I've you know talked about
you know the idea that I very few people
seem happy in America even happiness in
America seems to be a frenetic kind of
manic behavior that's not like a Nordic
satisfied and relaxed person it's like a
Matic junkie whose dealer is just called
the back that is happiness in America
it's like somebody very very excited to
tell you how good something's going for
them uh but it's not like that calm cool
collected
deep satisfaction that maybe the Finish
have
so here in the article on March 20th
United Nations sustainable development
Solutions Network release its annual
World happiness report what a
interesting thing which rates well-being
in countries around the world for the
sixth year in a row Finland was ranked
at the very top they keep winning
they always win
but when they interview them
individually they go I wouldn't say that
I consider as very happy said Nina
Hanson 58 a high school English teacher
from a mid-sized City on finland's West
Coast I'm a little suspicious of that
word actually which I I am too Nina
they spoke to about a dozen Finns a
Zimbabwean immigrant a folk metal
violinist a former Olympian and a
retired Dairy Farmer
about what supposedly makes Finland so
happy
our subjects raged in a in age from 13
to 88 and represented a variety of
genders sexual orientations ethnic
backgrounds and professions to get a
full picture of how happy Finnish people
are
um they came from Coca-Cola as well as
the capital Helsinki turku a city on the
southwestern coast and three villages in
southern eastern and western Finland and
I read the article and what it comes
down to is they like nature they like
welfare and they're satisfied with very
little
which is good but that's how you get
happy right they enjoy nature they
actually enjoy it like Americans don't
really enjoy nature unless we're
destroying it or we're using it for our
own gain
um nature in America for the most part
is kind of been ruined like we do have
Yellowstone we have some beautiful
national parks but most nature is just
you know it's hanging on by a thread
it's the fires are always burning down
there's droughts everywhere the Lakes
aren't at a high level so nature in
America takes a back seat you know there
are people that go out and do things in
nature but a lot of times that's murder
or rape I mean it's not oh you know
there's regular there's people that go
out and don't kill in the natural
environment but it's not our main thing
like our main thing is not the nature
like we have some pretty nature but our
main thing is like the cities the vibe
the clubs the drugs the money the cars
that you know and in Finland they like a
tree
like they like seeing green grass we
take nature and and put it on the
outside like we take fake moss and put
it on the outside of buildings or we
take trees and rip them out of the
ground and put them inside of a hotel
lobby we dominate nature which I think
is good like we don't let nature we're
not going to be Nature's [__] you know
like there's a lake in uh Austin called
Lake Travis which is heinous it's a
heinous Lake it's a man-made lake and
it's uh it looks like it's in a crater
like an asteroid hit the earth and
there's a crater and it's blue because
it's Limestone on the bottom it gives it
that nice color and they buy water from
Lake Mead and they buy water from
Colorado and they direct it via the dam
into this Lake Travis which is a heinous
Lake kind of I mean when you look at it
and and the drought has made the lake so
that the lake is not even full it's kind
of like
you know it's like the levels of the
lake aren't aren't good
so people go out and they go on boats
and they get hammered and they drink and
there's a place called Hippie Hollow
where they get naked and everybody's
like screaming and yelling and you know
I'm not this is a fun summer activity
but it's not really about the lake right
like it's not about it's just about like
we've created this big slip and slide
for adults to just you know to take part
in like it's about us it's not about the
lake we don't really give a [__] about
the lake we care about our ability to
use the lake to get drunk to use drugs
to dry fast on boats and have fun water
sports but that's what America views
uh nature it's like it's like an
impediment to our having a good time
it's like we you know the lake uh last
year the lake levels were low people
didn't care they're like [__] it it's
just hey this is uh the lakes are [__]
and it's a heinous like not a nice Lake
it's not a naturally occurring it's a
man-made lake we make Lakes
and we put some fish in them and we go
go out there and do it go out there and
get drunk get on the boat do the and
there's nothing wrong with it you know
get on the the [__] jet skis
have fun but we make nature to please us
whereas The Finnish people the Finns go
to Nature and their depression is lifted
because they're in nature and I don't
know what they do out there in it but
apparently they like it they also have a
very strong social uh safety net well
they're saying they're a psychological
benefits of nature in Finland
that these people there's psychological
benefits of nature like they go to
Nature and they feel better about
themselves they also have a nice welfare
state so nobody's cast out of society
for not performing
um
so rather than happy they're more likely
to characterize Finns as quite gloomy
a little Moody
and not given to unnecessary smiling so
they're just they're just these are
different types of people they're Nordic
um they're not they don't have that kind
of manic highs and lows
that Americans have
but they have sustainable lives like
their idea of success is being able to
meet basic needs that's the big
difference between those Nordic
countries and America they want like
basic needs a little house
a little fish
and a few potatoes a little family
and they and they have Art For Art's
Sake no one gives a [__] about what the
Finish do
they don't have a finished ice spice
they have just this for the sake of it
they have it for the sake of it like we
nothing in America is for the sake of it
nothing if you ain't trying to get big
it's not worth it in America nobody's
enjoying anything everybody in the back
of their head is thinking that whatever
the hell they're doing is going to lead
to something else The Finnish don't
believe that so the Finish enjoy uh
music uh and entertainment but they
enjoy it for the sake of it as opposed
to Americans who are like trying to get
their kids on the line for American Idol
so the kids can get famous and they can
retire like Americans just are chasing
Fame and chasing money this is part of
our culture we want fame and we want
money we don't really care about nature
does it that does not do anything for us
we want fame and we want money and if
we're not famous and Rich we want our
kids to be famous and Rich
you know the fins don't feel like that
they want their kids to have a little
house a little fish and little potatoes
and that's fine with them that's a nice
way to live America
we want our kids
to be famous
first
and Rich
we want our kids to be big time
big time we want to tell people like
that's my kid we don't care if they have
face tattoos if they're on drugs we
don't care if their lives are ruined we
don't care if they're in debt to record
companies we don't care if Hollywood is
molesting them we don't care if they're
being exploited by everyone in their
lives we don't care if they're if
literally their manager and agent are
stopping them from killing themselves
and throwing them back out on stage none
of that matters to us as long as they
are famous and Rich that is fine
that is fine and then the next step if
they're not famous when Rich is like
good job that you can tell people about
a decent house big house nice wife Nice
kids like look at that but first and
foremost we'd like them to be famous and
Rich and the Finns aren't doing this
their lives are not built on this
unsustainable Rat Race that Americans
are in Americans are constantly in this
rat race
of being the best at everything the most
successful putting in the most time
getting the big job getting the corner
office getting the big house in the pool
and the cars but the Finnish people but
but again I don't know what's better I
don't know what's better
I don't know what's better
is it better to have a little house with
a little fish and a little potatoes
and you it's a tiny little house and no
one really speaks
I speak occasionally
or is it better to live in a mansion
where everybody in their rooms is
plotting against everybody else
and they're plotting to try to get their
lives where they want them to be I don't
know
I don't know what's better do you want
to live in a place where you get excited
by something as stupid and gay as nature
is that like
something that you want to be a part of
I mean it's easy to say that yes
Americans are sick and our value system
is wrong it is and you know everything
and our country's rotted it has
but
the flip side of it is like the Finns
have never had any impact
culturally on the world and you could
say well America's impact is now
negative well maybe I'd agree with you
but we've certainly done some good
things I mean name me a Finnish movie
you know or something in terms of music
I mean I don't know it's not as easy to
just say like hey
The Finisher the happiest people in the
world
and we should all take a page out of
their book I don't know I don't know if
that's just easy to say is people
believe like if people
really want to do that spring is sprung
and our friends at manscape the leaders
in below the way screaming have the best
tools for some spring cleaning in your
pants trust me your confidence will be
blooming like the flowers look your best
at Spring and join the other eight
million men who trust manscape use code
Tim D to get 20 off free shipping at
manscape.com okay I'm telling you right
now
I love manscape I use it everyone I know
uses it everyone I know is satisfied
with it uh manscape they're going to
change the way that all the fellows can
take care of ourselves and groom with
the performance package 4.0 inside this
ball care bundle you'll find the
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer the weed whacker
ear nose and hair trimmer that comes in
handy the crop preserver ball deodorant
crop reviver toner ball
the performance boxer briefs and a
travel bag to hold all your goodies the
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer is an electronic
trimmer that provides their proprietary
Advanced Skin safe technology this
trimmer is designed to trim hair on
loose skin although your balls might
look like punching bags don't treat them
like one the lawnmower 4.0 also
waterproof and equipped with an LED
light so you can trim in the dark or the
shower have you ever met somebody who
finds nose hairs attractive the weed
whacker knows any an ear hair trimmer
provides proprietary skin safe
technology which helps reduce Nick snags
and tugs again the code is Tim D
save 20 off
free shipping with the code Tim D at
manscape.com 20 off free shipping code
timdham manscape.com if you enjoy the
podcast a great way to support us and
get yourself a gift or somebody you know
a gift it's no secret that injuries suck
I hate them it's paying the hospital
bills sometimes even missing days of
work it's literally the worst so if
you've been injured hiring a lawyer
could be the best decision you've ever
made I know a lot of you think hiring a
lawyer is hard and confusing but Morgan
and Morgan actually makes it super easy
how easy you ask with Morgan and Morgan
you can start a claim from your couch
and about six clicks if you don't want
to call that's okay you can simply text
back and forth with your lawyers and the
best part that it's free you only pay a
few in your case Morgan and Morgan
America's largest injury Law Firm 900
lawyers 100 offices 24 7 customer
service staff and they've recovered
listen many of you are sitting on the
couch Sue
sue someone
you're in a you have a problem you hurt
yourself you fell you slipped you
tripped
two your kid found someone's pool Sue
something's going on Sue
they've recovered over 15 billion
dollars for their clients all you have
to do is Sue
dial pound law or go for the people.com
Tim and Sue
that's dial pound law or
forthepeople.com Kim Sue
if you're hurt for any reason sue
someone else is responsible Sue
that's dial pound law people.com Tim Sue
your kid fell Sue
sell
this is a paid advertisement
so here's listen to this this is
interesting and this goes right to my
point Public Funding for education in
the Arts including individual artist
grants gives people like his wife Herta
a mixed media artist the freedom to
pursue their creative Passions
it also affects the kind of work that we
make because we don't have to think of
the commercial value of art said Mr
kiskey
so a lot of what these artists make here
is very experimental listen Herta sucks
and she's making a lot of crap
and the reality is the government's
funding that crap and there's nothing
wrong with that on its face
but the reality is it's not good
mixed media art is rarely good and
there's no way that this [__] is doing
anything good there's no way there's no
way that first of all I know some of the
biggest losers in the world if you were
to give them grants from the government
to make sure so that they didn't have to
work and they could just make art it
would not make the art good it wouldn't
it would relieve the financial burdens
on them but that wouldn't necessarily
make them valuable as artists
so I I I mean can we get some or hurt is
there anything that we can see here from
Herta the The Finnish mixed media artist
because I want to be proven wrong but I
have a sneaky suspicion that it's a
waste of everybody's time it could be oh
yeah hurta here it is hertagiski
now I could be wrong here but this is
what you get in a country with a social
safety net where people uh you know are
you know satisfied and I'm not so what
is this what am I even looking at what
is it I kind of like that this is called
after the end I kind of like that that's
not bad after the end what do you even
see here well it's like a picture of uh
it's I don't know but I it's not
horrible
well now go up there what is this with
the two what is that two eggs
oh boy this is what you do when you
don't have to think of the commercial
value of Art
and everybody's satisfied
to just loaf around and eat a little
fish and little potatoes
what else what other masterpieces
what is that a torture chamber
I think it's like uh yeah I mean again
you know
are you trading this
are you trading Tina Turner or Elvis or
or biggie for this for Herta
let's be honest these are the questions
we have to ask ourselves
is that what we want do we want a
society
where we don't have Run DMC but we have
this where this [__] took scrunchies
and put them on a metal pipe and is
calling his heart and that's what the
government pays for the government pays
for this [__] to put scrunchies on a
metal pipe and call it art and that's
what they pay for you know what I think
would make her better working a Taco
Bell for minimum wage
and then fighting her way out of that
sorry Herta
so I don't know it's not as simple but
another another thing I wanted to talk
about to deviate from this point a
little bit
I and this is we're staying in the realm
of art because I do I'm getting more
into art now
um because it's it's by the way
you know I I I've been lucky enough to
do well enough to own a few homes but I
don't really have art
so if you wanted to send me the and
something on Instagram in DM
if you're an artist that does cool [__]
I will pay you maybe potentially to do
some work
for something like
I have a house on Long Island and I want
like a uh I'm trying to think what I
want as like a painting
for that house I don't know yet but
maybe we'll correspond if you're a good
painter not if you're not good don't
don't contact me if you're not good I
want to see your work that you've done
like maybe in a gallery setting I mean
what's funny about that I wanna I don't
want
somebody you're not going to try this
out for the first time but if you're an
established painter maybe we can work
together on like a nice piece of art
um
now I want to talk about something
because you know when you have
successful parents often your passions
are subordinated
because the reality of their lives uh
are so big that you
are relegated to the background
especially as an artist
what's nice
about the Biden family
is that is not the case
what's positive about the Biden family
is there's an artist in the family and
they allow him
to stand
on his own
and and present his work now this is
from the post Hunter Biden Works
featured alongside art World Heavy
Hitters
Hunter Biden is back in the Big Apple as
his newest work will be featured in a
New York show alongside some of the art
world's renowned abstract
painters
Bridging the abstract a group exhibition
that opens April 6th at the George
Berger Gallery in SoHo
includes some of the first son's latest
Works alongside paintings by Elaine de
kooning and Helen
frankensteiler thaler thaler
frankenthiler I mean listen so Biden 53
will be on hand for the opening he's
coming in for the oh you would think
that they would stash him somewhere you
would think they'd go you turned in a
laptop
of you [__] [__] and you smoking
crack and waving guns around your father
is the president you have to go away now
and we basically have to start telling
people you're dead
no no no no no no they are supporting
him as he has an art exhibition in
Manhattan that's a good family
that is an understanding and encouraging
family that after everything he's done
the crack the [__] the guns dating his
brothers why all of that dead brother's
wife all of that they're still like hey
he's an artist
Hunter's an artist no matter what he's
got his show and it's it's coming into
election season and they don't care they
do not care over the last several months
investigators have demanded details on
collections
on collectors who paid for Hunter's art
which has been valued between 75 000 and
500 000. what will he do with the money
now
such a great idea by the way to give him
hundreds of thousands of dollars where
will that end up
now among the other painters featured in
Bridging the owl who cares
I will say this it's nice to see a
family
supporting
a God can we get into the I would love
to go to this thing because I will I
will support how great would it be to
own a hunter Biden original
is anything any good do we have any do
we have any can we see some of the work
that might be displayed is that one yeah
this one's called Haiku that's not bad
it's better than that [__] in Finland
this is my point about America this is
the point
what makes you a good artist is a crack
addiction and having your father be the
president
you don't get that in Finland but this
is actually good go up to Haiku again I
like this
I like Haiku make that big this is good
this is much better than that [__] in
Finland
I'll tell you this I'm I'm fully on
board is there anything else can we look
at anything else from him because this
is not bad but this is what I mean about
the struggle making the art the struggle
makes the art if you give everybody
everything and
you know they have a simple life now you
might say the middle Hunter is a very
privileged kid well of course he is but
his life was so insane that he got he
became a demon from Hell which is what
made the art good he wasn't walking
around going oh the nature is so pretty
he was smoking crack in the Ukraine and
running scams that got us into a war
that is that's why we have good art take
a look at that this is nice I actually
like this
can I get in is there a way to get in
can I just get in I will bid on these
maybe kind of not really but I might
is there a way to get in this Gallery
look this up please because I don't want
to miss this
I actually enjoy the work I was a junkie
myself I didn't do great work when I was
on crizzle but I was uncooked not
cracked maybe that's why but I'll tell
you right now I support the guy and I
like that his family is pushing him more
front and center even with a laptop of
crime or or what looks to well what is
definitely crime
um but could be even much worse than we
know uh a scandal potentially it's great
that the family's just kind of pushing
him front and center and going hey no
matter what he's an artist Hunter's an
artist
and we're gonna treat him like that
I'm hey man
you talk about a supportive family
you took about a mom and a dad to give a
[__] well the dad and I mean the mother
is not I don't think Jill's the mom is
she she might be I can't keep track that
family's at so many [__] problems
we're indicting president Trump by the
way I mean he looks so happy I'm going
in this scout by the way when is this
it's April 6th so there's a chance it'll
be going on when you're in New York too
[__] I'm I'm in uh Minnesota I think or
Grand Rapids I forgot
can we call the gallery right now call
the gallery right now they're probably
closed call the gallery right now I want
a hunter I want 100 by the original I
want a hunter Biden original right now I
wanna I will I will I need to get
invited
to that Gallery because I want one of
this guy's paintings he's much better
than this [__] Herta in Finland who was
not impressive at all
I'm glad you're happy because the rest
of your [__] sucks over there
they're probably not going to answer
it's after hours but this is a big event
I don't know that it'll matter maybe
I'll leave a message
nobody works
you'd think for the hunter Biden show
they'd stay open late he likes late
night stuff late night activities
he should have just painted a laptop
to be honest that would have been kind
of cool all right [__] it they're not
gonna answer if they're not gonna answer
then [__] them
but I do want to I do want to go
and see what he's got going on how many
of you wish there was a better solution
to paying off your debt PBS dad has
customized savings options for anyone
struggling with credit cards personal
loans collections medical bills with
Rising interest rates of the cost of
living in an all-time high now is the
time to finally take initiative with
your debt stop waiting and start saving
with your own custom debt savings
options from PDS debt PDS debt is giving
our qualified listeners free debt
savings analysis just for completing the
30-second online debt assessment at
pdsdebt.com Tim
you will receive a full breakdown
on how to save it on interest each month
and the quickest way to kick take care
of your debt
if you're making payments every month on
your debt your balances aren't going
down this program is for you your
savings options are made Customs from
your budget
and situation everyone with over ten
thousand dollars or more in debt
qualifies there is no minimum credit
card score required
bad and Fair Credit Acceptance save
thousands of interest and fees pay off
your debt in a fraction of the time
pedia's debt is offering free debt
analysis to our listeners just for
completing the quick and easy debt
management assessment at
www.pdsdebt.com Tim how proud am I and I
have uh my own debt collection
advertisement
pdsdebt.com
Tim just like the old days
that's PDS d-e-b
-t because that's a tricky one it's got
the b in there
slash Tim take back your Financial
Freedom today and get that jet ski
pdsdead.com Tim Dead with a B Donald
Trump being indicted for uh
paying off Stormy Daniels the porn star
this is kind of a nothing Burger in my
estimation obviously no President should
be above the law but they all are
and presidents have done so many
different things from you know
legalizing and authorizing torture in
violation of the Geneva conventions and
I know they ran legal cover from that by
having their lawyers write whatever the
hell they wanted to and we've had Obama
with you know
the warrantless wiretaps and the drone
strikes and killing an American citizen
and all this stuff now of course we can
always say that like well they didn't
really break any laws because they just
brought a bunch of lawyers in the White
House and said uh make up a rationale
for us to do this and they do
um but it's amazing this is all the only
thing they've got Trump on he's a real
estate developer and these Shady Fox
real estate people they pay off
everybody this is what they do they just
pay people to shut up they pay people to
do what they want
um this is also what wealthy people do
right former president Donald Trump's
indictment by New York Grand Jury has
thrust the nation into Uncharted
political legal and historical Waters
because this is the first time that a
president has paid off
uh porn star and we've known about it I
guess Bill Clinton has done it and we
knew about it but Paula Jones I think we
paid off is not a pornstar although she
maybe had done porn
um
this is the first time a president has
been indicted after leaving office the
Manhattan District Attorney's office has
been investigating Trump in connection
with his alleged role in a hush money
payment scheme and cover-up involving
adult film star Stormy Daniels
so my my thought on this and my entire
uh belief system here is that
this feels like
a stunt
and I think it'll backfire and I think
it could only help Trump
and I think this is what people have
done since Trump has emerged onto the
scene
every attempt to take out Trump has only
served to help him because what Trump's
really good at is fighting
and what is really not that great at is
governing
he's got too many things that get in the
way his own ego
his his Petty Behavior
his inability to be loyal to certain
people throws people under the bus like
he's got a lot of personal issues that
prevent him from carrying out uh a
governing strategy
um but what he's really really good with
he's amazing at is fighting when he's up
against the ropes he's good
so I don't see this doing anything but
helping him this is something that he'll
probably
Coast you know and win the nomination
Ron DeSantis is boring he's [__]
boring whatever you say about him and I
certainly don't believe he's Hitler I
don't believe any of the things people
are saying
um some of the stuff he's doing down
there is probably an overreaction
um
but you know I mean you know I I do
understand where it comes from we'll
talk about that in a minute but Rhonda
sandis is a boring bully he looks like a
cop none of it's It's not coming
together
I mean I watched this guy and I was
incredibly immediately after Trump I'm
so bored by Rhonda Santos I'm like oh my
God it's like a cop who comes into
school talking about drugs with the
intended uh purpose of of getting you to
rat on your friends
like that's the type of energy Ron
DeSantis has like a cop who's trying to
get you to nark on your your boys
because he's like now listen we found
this bag of weed and we called the
police you know and then the cop shows
up and he's like this is a serious
matter and the only way to handle this
is for someone to come forward or if you
know who's weed this is like that's the
energy Ron DeSantis has like a a school
cop rat energy not
what Trump has which is a crazy uh
Riverboat Captain casino gambling Tycoon
Psychopathic energy which we're all used
to
we're all used to that energy because
it's more fun
so Rhonda sand it like Play and play any
clip of Ron DeSantis talking about
anything I mean anything about anything
we're bored I mean I'm like can someone
I mean I'd rather watch season six a
house of cards that's the bad one
without Kevin Spacey
today Trump supporters rallied on Long
Island at an event held by that's right
Long Island his potential rival for the
Republican Presidential nomination and
as CBS 2's Jennifer busram all right
stop that for a minute I love that
DeSantis is doing rallies in Long Island
because he knows like he's like I gotta
win if I can win over these Psychopaths
you know people just show up with a
bacon egg and I'm so excited I'm going
to be there for a few months uh coming
up soon by the way third show the power
amount is on sale we sold out to the
third show we're about a little less
than half sold but it's uh it's coming
up so if you want to get tickets you can
uh and and listen and here's a reality I
know many of you are budgeting there's
still enough for the Percocet there's
still enough for the booze
long for DeSantis to address Trump's
indictment
he wants to downgrade felonies to
misdemeanors uh really really dangerous
stuff and then what does he do he turns
around does a flimsy indictment against
a former president of the United States
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis wasted get
a Speed Shop of just him talking this is
the news covering him
but if you just get him speaking you
will see how truly boring he is it's
just that it's it's the tone
you know Trump had this musicality to
when he talked it was interesting it was
like listening to a jazz band and then
Rhonda Santos is just very it's there's
it's like a doll go to his victory
speech even that was dull
it's just dull
well thank you so much no over these
past four years this isn't going to do
it any major challenges for the people
of our state for the citizens of the
United States not gonna happen above all
for the cause of Freedom we saw freedom
in our very way of life and so many
other jurisdictions in this country
Wither on the vine
Florida held yeah see I even agree with
what he's saying but it's like he's just
not it's not going to do it I mean Trump
as my friend Ray said will beat this guy
from a prison cell I mean trouble win
the election like Nelson Mandela in a
jail I don't know if Nelson won an
election in a jail but I know he was
jailed but my point is that I just don't
see uh Ron catching Donald here I I
don't you know listen again if you let
them just have a campaign where Trump
had to answer for certain things like
again you know more and more is coming
out about the vaccine every day I think
the W I think the World Health
Organization is like now it's not
recommended for healthy teens I believe
that and children which is big if that's
the case
um Trump authorized in fact Trump was
like this is the vaccine is the big you
know success story of my presidency this
is you know my Administration right so
Trump also shut things down DeSantis
kept them open
um
the world health organizations vaccine
experts have revised their Global
covid-19 vaccine vaccination
recommendations and healthy kids and
teenagers considered low priority may
not need to get a shot that's big this
is big this is actually massive this is
literally a massive thing the World
Health Organization is like yeah
[Applause]
I guess not this was the thing that they
were firing people for this is the thing
that Trump said was the biggest
achievement of his administration if
DeSantis was kind of hitting him on that
without being so [__] boring out of
trump and if the story wasn't Trump's
[__] indictment the story might
literally be like oh to Santa's cap
should open Trump actually kind of
folded a little bit and you know hyped
all of this stuff the vaccine that it
was a big achievement and the reality is
it's just not it hasn't done what
anybody wanted it to do and now the who
is coming out and going listen we don't
know if kids and young adults need it
and that's because of the myocard I just
saw that crazy [__] I'd be thrown off
YouTube If I said any of this a year ago
or two years ago but now this is all
common like the news has to now use like
uh phrases like it was a he's a 19 year
old it was a routine heart attack like
that's happening now so there's this
major so there's things that you could
hit Trump on that you wouldn't even
think you could but now the whole
narrative is going to be dominated by
the fact that he paid off or maybe paid
off a porn star
is a campaign Finance violation which no
one really gives a [__] about
so this just does nothing but helps him
he's probably going to be back I don't
see anyone beating him
uh DeSantis has a record that
Republicans will Embrace but the actual
guy is just not as electric as the Don
it's just I'm sorry
and I thought Trump was done a few
months ago I thought he was finished and
I was talking to people at dinner and it
was like he's done and now he's indicted
I think he's got a better chance than
ever now I'm like I think he's in again
I think he's in again he's been indicted
but that's the word that's Trump World
rules you don't understand
Trump without the indictment you know
just fading away that announced me the
edit Mar-A-Lago it was his passion was
in there you know but he's gotten better
he's gotten more she's gotten a little
sharper in this campaign and he was
indicted so now he's digging in and
fighting which is what now it could be
wrong he could still crumble it might
not work but
I give him a better chance now
than
a lot of things a lot of people keeps is
great people are bald and sometimes that
sucks
the reality is a lot of people are
trying to stay with their hair and you
know how they do it they got to keep the
hair they have on their head that's when
they do it two out of three men will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they're 35. more than 50 million
men in the U.S suffer from male pattern
baldness keeps us more five-star reviews
than any of its competitors
I'll just tell you a quick story here I
had a friend
whose wife sat him down one day and said
listen if you lose the rest of your hair
I'm going to leave you
and he said what do you mean she goes
well I don't really love you we got
married very hastily and I didn't know
you're going to lose this much hair she
goes the reason I've stayed married to
you is for our child
um I don't want her to witness a divorce
I want her to have her parents
um
together while she grows up but I don't
like you I I don't even I don't love you
but I don't even like you and I would
get out of this if not for the kid
Bianca
and he said well this is coming as a
shock he goes but I don't really even
love you really he goes you're right we
did get married kind of hastily but we
had this beautiful young daughter Bianca
we both love and he goes I don't even
know why we call her Bianca
who even came up with that name and she
goes well it was I think it was like a
great aunt of mine who I used to always
visit she was kind of a wealthy spinster
who drank a lot she'd let me drink a
little wine every now and then and
he's like our daughter's named after an
alcoholic and she's like well not an
alcoholic she was kind of fun and I
don't know I feel like she was like a
fun free woman but he goes alone like a
spinster like she was alone she had a
husband we don't know what happened
would she kill him no but anyway that's
renamed our daughter after he's like I
never even knew that I didn't even know
that we named our daughter and just I
thought you were like closer with her
than that she was like well I would go
see her sometimes in the Summers
she was like this wealthy woman named
Bianca who just got drunk and she would
let me drink and he goes all right well
I'm glad that's who he named our
daughter after and she's like well
whatever it's a pretty name he goes yeah
and she goes well listen we don't love
each other
but we've got this kid and we can't
really afford to get divorced right
because our two incomes pay for this
little dump of the house that we live in
and I don't hate the house sure the
yard's not as big as I'd want it to be
but it's fine and during the summer
Bianca's friends can come over and at
least she has a backyard to play in
she's living the life that that you know
that that we think is good a Suburban
kid life
so if we break up we both get shitty
places and we're shuffling her from one
place to another place
it's not a good idea so I think we
should
we should stay together for as long as
humanly possible to give this child a
chance at life
and she goes I'm Gonna Get You keeps
that way you can keep the hair that you
have in your head
and he goes really
he goes do I have to go to a doctor she
goes no you actually never have to go to
a doctor's office ever it's it's easy to
get refill reminders you'll never run
low on the products you need and you'll
keep your hair and he goes this is
amazing he goes I almost love you again
but I really don't LOL she goes listen I
get it
he goes well I don't understand this
stuff I'm new to this she goes well they
have 24 7 care and support so you don't
have to talk to me if you have a problem
they have a network of medical advisors
prescribers and Care Specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality and he goes well I bet this is
going to cost an arm and a [__] leg
and you're gonna throw it in my face all
the time that you're the one I have
you're the reason I have hair
and she goes listen
it's low cost
treatment plans are affordable typically
half the cost of Pharmacy prices so the
reality is
he goes on keeps this is true
he goes on keeps and he he literally
does not lose any more hair
thank God he went on when he did
because it takes treatments four to six
months to work he doesn't lose any more
hair
okay
so she comes to him and she goes listen
now that you don't you're not losing
your hair anymore I can't believe this
but I'm actually starting to get
attracted to you again you know I know I
told you I didn't love you I still don't
but I feel more attracted to you now
that you you're keeping your hair like
you're doing something good for yourself
and he goes you know what
I gotta be honest I feel more confident
I feel better
and I feel like
this is good that I have hair right so
he goes maybe do you think we can try
to love each other
could we could we try to do this not
only for Bianca's sake but for ours we
don't want to be miserable in this home
okay
so they go out to dinner
they go out to dinner one night in a
little place called Long Island New York
and they take two separate cars because
many couples that hate each other do
he was coming from work and this was
date night and day night
and they go out for date night
and they actually have a great time
it's like they're meeting for the first
time he has hair
and she's the reason for it
and they're eating and drinking and
having a great time
and it's amazing
and it's actually like
you know this is fixed and he says to
her he goes you think I can get lucky
tonight she goes you might just get
lucky and you know they hadn't been
having sex so this was a big deal and
it's all because he went to keps.com Tim
Dillon
it's all because he went to
k-e-e-p-s.com Tim Dillon so they have
this great little dessert it's a
raspberry cheesecake
at the end and and it's getting very fun
and flirty and sexy
and they both leave to go home
she is hit by a drunk driver going the
wrong way on the Parkway and she's
banned
he gets home and he doesn't call her
right away because he thinks that
potentially she's picking up some sex
stuff
so he doesn't call her and he keeps
calling her phone and it's going to
voicemail and he's like oh beyond God
Mommy's coming home soon Mommy's coming
home soon
and then he gets the call
from the state troopers
and he goes
and he's his head's racing a million
miles a minute
and he goes and he sees her
and he has to identify her and it's just
the head
and he asked his state trooper can he
hold her head and they're very
uncomfortable with this
and they don't want to let him do it but
he just because he he's left Bianca with
the grandmother and then he just holds
her head
for a minute not not in a gross way not
in a morbid way but he's holding her
head and he's running his hands through
her hair
and then he starts running his hands
through his hair
and he said
her Legacy on this Earth will be my hair
her Legacy will be my hair
keps.com Tim Dillon if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss do it
the Nashville shooter let's talk about
this is a sticky situation because the
Nashville shooter was a trans shooter
and a lot of people are going back and
forth about that
um and what that means now there's been
a few people
a few shooters that have been trans
recently now the vast majority of
Shooters obviously have not been trans
but there's been a few
um Shooters recently that have been
trans and I wanted to talk about this
because I was I was sitting there on the
plane in first class and I was thinking
uh and by the way what's good about
United first class is it's first class
but is it you know I mean it's like what
are we what are we doing here
um I was sitting there I was thinking
about the trans issue because it's so I
was listening to this podcast that Megan
Phelps Roper did with JK Rowling about
you know the trials of The Witch Trials
of JK Rowling about you know the author
of Harry Potter and how much Flack she
got for just wading into that issue
right and saying men and men and women
are women in trans manner trans men and
trans women are trans women but there's
a difference between biological women
and trans women and this is what JK
Rowling said
and then everybody went nuts and got
angry she's still a billionaire and
she's still fine but I was listening to
this I was thinking about this so much I
was I was thinking about I'm like how
did this invade our politics to the
level that it has how has this suck the
energy out I mean we don't talk about
anything anymore the banks almost
collapsed two weeks ago we don't even
talk about it anymore no it speaks of it
the border is a mess no one speaks of it
no one speaks of it it's trans trans
every day every minute and it's weird
seems a bit a little designed to be
honest
listen the trans community in America
has existed forever there's always been
people that that have felt like they are
in the wrong body they have a condition
called gender dysphoria and they've gone
to certain links uh to fix that
obviously hormones and um surgery and
things like that are have gotten better
technology has gotten better people have
been able to uh physically transition in
ways they couldn't if they had those
feelings years ago
but the trans Community has been around
in America for a a a pretty long time
and it hasn't been
this like contentious thing where
everybody is fighting over it right
women that that were born biological men
that then transitional women a lot of
them would use a woman's bathroom and
maybe there'd be some people making
comments and I know that trans people
have dealt with bigotry and they've
dealt with you know violence that
they've dealt with all that [__] gay
people have black people any minority
really has dealt with that right a
hundred percent I'm not saying they
haven't but for the most part this
wasn't the issue it is now
um and you'd imagine
see this is what I would think if the
medication was getting better the
hormones whatever they're taking a
testosterone estrogen whatever it is if
surgeries were getting better people
were getting more this was easier and
maybe even cheaper to do this would be
being diminished as an issue and not
like like
blowing up
it seems like the medical advancements
would make these things easier for
people to do if they felt like they
really needed to do them
and this wouldn't be such a big deal
it would be a very personal thing people
would go hi I'm Jack and now I'm Jill
and your friends and family would go
hello Jill you know or whatever or
they'd go you're going to hell whatever
it is there would be it would be a
personal thing between you and the
people that you know your close friends
and family but now now this leaves out
kids right because this is why this has
become such a controversial issue it is
specifically about what ideas should
children be
confronted with and at what age
what age do children need to learn
certain things
and once those children have learned
those things
what age is it appropriate for those
children to make medical decisions about
their future and their life and that's
really the the point that has become
incredibly divisive right let's leave
out for a second the drag queen Story
Hour which we've talked about before on
the show and that seems to be the uh you
know the the cultural battleground of
the day the drag queen's reading in the
library but but the the deeper issue the
more important issue is
can a seven-year-old
make a decision
about who they are
at that age I say no most people I know
say no
uh the most gay people I know say no to
that
most reasonable rational sane people say
that when you're under 18 you're gonna
go through all kinds of weird feelings
and you're gonna have hormones are
raging and you're not gonna know exactly
what direction you want to go many of
the people that don't end up
transitioning that have feelings like
this end up being gay or lesbian
and it's strange it's a it's an odd
fixation with bringing these issues to
children and letting children make
decisions about who they are doesn't
make any sense if you've ever met
children
this makes zero sense that teachers and
schools are telling children you could
be any gender that you want to be today
that is not a conversation for math
class this is most this is most people
I have friends that are more liberal on
this issue they're more Progressive and
they say well there are such a thing as
trans kids and I said well I I believe
that to be true
of course
but I still think I don't know if they
should be blocking puberty
they should be taking pharmaceutical
drugs they should be denying themselves
the opportunity to go through puberty
and see if any of that changes or Alters
the way they feel about their gender
there's always a way to correct things
later in life I know people that have
transitioned in their early 20s and
they're living lives and they're happy
so I think that's what it it comes down
to it comes down to kids and children
you know for most people listen there's
people that hate trans people there's
people that don't want trans people
around there's people that are going to
hate everybody there's people that hate
everybody no matter what you can fixate
on those people but the vast majority of
people don't care
they don't they just don't want
children
being introduced to certain ideas before
those children are ready for it
that's what most people most people do
not care they're not sitting around
hating you if you're gay they're not
sitting around hating you if you're
trans they don't really have the time
this is not a country that like you know
people don't have the time to be as
hateful as maybe they'd want to be they
don't have the time they're running
around
um they just don't want
children being exposed to certain things
because children are very confused
by their nature their kids they're
easily it's easy
for and it's some of these parents with
the Trans kids I I have a real I have a
soft spot for but then some of them and
I'll get a little bit of trouble for
saying this but most people understand
what I'm saying some of the parents it's
a little like a munchausen's by proxy
where it's like they are taking
a lot of interest
in this thing that their kids are
feeling and it almost feels like the
parent is somehow deriving
some type of when Munch houses is where
you make a kid sick and I'm not saying
being trans is being sick but I'm saying
a lot of these parents are being very
encouraging to their children and maybe
steering them knowingly or unknowingly
into being into being uh trans perhaps
because parents are sometimes
you know I I had friends that their
parents were very encouraging and trying
to help them a lot and what it did was
the opposite of what they wanted it to
do
and I don't mean that you should if your
kid has these feelings you shouldn't
shut them down
but I don't know if you should parade
your kid around like a political
statement and I see some parents doing
that and I wonder about the health the
mental health of those parents that are
parading their children around like a
political statement instead of a human
being that doesn't make any sense to me
that's a little weird
and as far as the sports thing goes
it's so hard for me
to to to come up with a an opinion here
that like
is anti
-hitting women because sometimes they do
need a tap but
it seems in Combat Sports
specifically biological men have a
little bit of an advantage even after
they've transitioned so watching them
beat women although there may be reasons
not to ever beat a woman but to give her
a like a 1920 style
tap just a light one
it's a comedy show but the point is
what I'm saying is that it's very
difficult
for me to just have to say we really
shouldn't just we should just not hit
women but I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna say it we shouldn't hit women
so I don't again if you want to compete
in those things but the reality of this
situation is also if you're like a
female athlete and every female sport is
now dominated by a trans female athlete
there is a there is a conversation to be
had
news is all of these things can be
solved by Common Sense and rationality
and then we can go back to talking about
the banks failing uh the nuclear war and
things that I consider to be more
important because I think there is a
rational reasonable
I don't want to say middle ground
because I you know the word Middle
Ground implies that like there has to be
some great compromise man I don't think
there has to be any compromise made I
think that people should listen if you
bring your children
to
drag queen Story Hour that they're your
children
they're your children
if you bring your children to get
hormones they're your children
I don't I think you're doing uh them a
great disservice and there are certain
states that are going to ban that and
there are certain states that won't
but you know there are
families and there are people that are
gonna have kids and they're gonna raise
them in in whichever way they see fit I
just think the whole thing because I was
thinking about to sit on a plane lizards
trans everything is Trent and then you
look around and you're like where all
the transmit and there's there's there's
a few of them for sure but they're not
everywhere this is a small crew this is
a minority of people that should be
protected with rights like they should
have rights and obviously people that
[__] with them should go to jail like
people that [__] with any group or
anyone in general should go to jail but
it's such a big issue
and it so dominates everything
and I'm like
this [__] JK Rowling
wrote a book called Harry Potter which
Christian people were saying was a devil
book and you know George W Bush was like
she's promoting Witchcraft and all these
crazy things right and so she got like
that [__] feedback when Harry Potter
came out and then she made a billion
dollars and she's got theme parks all
over the world and then just basically
said listen
women
you don't have the right to have spaces
that are their own and then people just
want [__] nuts
they went knots
and I'm not saying that on the other
side that the people don't overdo it
right because they you know the people
that are obsessed with it on the other
side who think that it's all about
people trying to [__] their kids or it's
all about this and that and it's we need
to go back to a Christian theocracy
that's not going to win a lot of people
over either
but because I don't think it's I don't
think it's all these teachers or
pedophiles I think these teachers are
completely
untethered from reality
and when people are untethered from
reality as many of them are
they push all of these ideological
agendas that are not
that are not
practical in any way and and that's what
happens to people that get really into
any ideology they forget that there's an
actual world out there with actual human
beings that tend to behave in ways that
aren't necessarily the ways that you
this ideology you believe in would
prescribe them to behave and you forget
that kids are [__] kids and they're
going to be confused and they're going
to take back things they say and they're
gonna go I don't feel that way anymore
and this and that the other thing but
they're so wrapped up in the idea that
there's there's a political uh thing
here that these kids have to be
themselves and stop trans get us high
it's like every discussion about trans
rights cannot cannot devolve into people
screaming stop trans genocide that's
like crazy it's like anybody that told
me to eat better I'd be like stop fat
genocide it's like I just suggested you
eat a salad like there needs to be we
gotta rein it in we are a country of
like people that are constantly on the
verge of an emotional breakdown everyone
you speak to is on the verge of a
nervous breakdown
and every grifter in the world is out
right now trying to make this into the
biggest issue and we've let them I mean
it's every day it's every every day
there's this issue and only this issue
at the expense of so many other issues
so that that's my piece on it leave kids
alone let them grow up
when they're 18 they could do what they
want to do some will do the wrong thing
then but you can't stop them you know
listen I I had friends that joined the
military and their parents were like we
don't want you to join the military
um you know and for whatever reason
they're like we're worried about you
we're in a war
this feels like Vietnam this was during
Iraq so we're doing 2003.
and I had friends who were joining the
military and their parents were like
listen this feels like Vietnam this
feels like uh not a great War
I I you know I understand that you want
to join the military but can't you just
you know do a Long Island you know have
a Long Island life like live in our
basement sell drugs at home like
whatever just wait it out and some of my
friends I don't think nobody I knew died
in Iraq I knew friends of friends that
died in the military there but
they joined the military because your
parents didn't really have any control
over them at that point they had
graduated high school they were adults
and they were going to go and do what
they felt like they had to do
but anybody who's [__] 13 or 14 years
old who has no idea what's going on
that may be being influenced by their
friends or whatever
you know
this is not somebody who should be
making permanent medical decisions about
the rest of their life this is not a to
me this isn't like a controversial point
of view I know there's a gray area I
know there's kids that have legitimate
Real Deal gender dysphoria there are a
few of them absolutely it's not as many
as you would think and that can be dealt
with with doctors and and therapists and
I still don't think even those kids
should be making medical decisions but
that could maybe be a lot of like you
could be dressed in a certain way you
could be doing some cognitive behavioral
therapy there's all kinds of ways to
handle it where it's not like hey let's
get [__] big Pharma involved in
giving everybody the solution to
everything and a lot of people that take
these drugs I mean if you watch this to
think about the Tavistock clinic in the
UK a lot of people that take these drugs
aren't happier
on the other side of that because maybe
there is a certain amount of people that
are are experiencing
mental issues that are on the autism
spectrum that are not they don't
genuinely have gender dysphoria they're
having weird feelings and they're
looking around on the internet and going
I wonder what this is and they're
matching up some of those feelings with
some of the things that uh people have
that have gender dysphoria and they're
putting them together and now they're
going okay if I transition medically
it's going to help me and then they do
that and then they don't feel
the way they wanted to feel you know so
again this is just it always amazes me
how much this has dominated the
discourse and now the the
the answer to me is just so easy and it
is it is less is more helicopter
parenting I don't think is a good idea I
I believe in the less is more assistive
the Boomers were in this regard and this
and the only regard
great parents in this and I talk about
this on stage I'm not going to do it
here timberlandcomedy.com but the Boomer
parenting style which was basically
you're talking but I'm not hearing you
if you if you were a boomer and your
kids were talking you were not listening
unless they were bleeding and then you
were yelling at them for being hurt
Boomers didn't give a [__] this is the
one thing that I'm going to say can we
have an Applause sound effect for the
Boomers because this is the one thing
that the Boomers get credit for they did
not listen to their children all the
time this is a huge thing for the
Boomers
and I think the Boomers should be yes
give them their due
they did not care what their children
were feeling ever
they didn't care who their kids thought
they were
the Boomers were like figure it out and
get out of my house
get out of my house you eat my food
Boomers treated you like a roommate they
met off Craigslist my friend's mother
would go yeah eat the food yeah here's
the shower the water bill I mean but
it's the one thing I will say
about the Boomers is that they didn't
care I think maybe
we should return to letting kids be kids
and letting them go through some [__]
and not taking everything they do
seriously not bringing them to a doctor
not doing anything permanent to their
body letting them figure this [__] out
on their own I I truly believe it is the
one area where the Boomers were far
superior
to the parents we have now
that it feels like they're just hanging
on every word their 12 or 13 year old
says it's just not
it's just not a reality so anyway uh
timleconne.com for tickets who are on
the road till uh mid-june we're in
Chicago we're in San Francisco or in
Milwaukee we're in some cool places
we'll see everybody else in the fall uh
we're taking the summer off the podcast
and uh on YouTube you can like And
subscribe we're on patreon uh and we
will see you there we'll see you here
thank you so much good night